support move university and the
production of more video tutorials by
making the financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
of move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy so earlier we mentioned that
chemistry was the study of matter and
the way that matter changes so when
we're talking about matter there are
some laws that we need to take into
account first one being the law of mass
conservation sometimes mentioned as the
law of conservation of mass and so
before we get into what it is let the
thing about who stated this law it was
this french dude named Antoine Lavoisier
I think that's how you pronounce it if
you're French anything that was horrible
I'm sorry but anyway he's the one who
stated this law and it was based on his
experiments with combustion he had some
combustion experiments that he was
working on and he said this law based on
that so what does the logs would
actually say basically says that during
a chemical reaction which is actually
pretty important there during a chemical
reaction the total mass of the
substances does not change okay and
there are some key words I want to
highlight okay during a chemical
reaction chemical reaction okay the
total mass of course does not change
right does not change so so what does
that really mean right that's the
question here and it's really just best
explain with an example at least in my
opinion so if you look down here we got
three different general reactions here
the first one where we have some dates
some compound or substance a and some
substance be that we're adding together
and they are reacting hence they're
called the reactants called the
reactants because they are reacting
together and they're giving the products
right the things that we're producing in
this reaction products c and d two
separate substances so what does the law
say according to this reaction is this a
chemical reaction yes it's cow
the total mass of the substances does
not change what that basically means is
that if we think about the mass of a
which I'm going to level label here as
mass subscript or M subscript a take the
massive a and we add it to the mass of B
whatever that is that's going to equal
the mass of c plus the mass of D so
let's just say that the mass of a plus
the mass of be just happen to be equal
to 50 grams this reaction will occur
between a and B to give us the product C
and D and it will be left with only C
and D the mass of c plus the mass of D
will also equal 50 grams that 50 grams
that we started with is the 50 grams is
we is still there in as 50 grams even
though it's just in a different form
right so that's one example same idea
here if the massive a plus the mass of B
equals 50 grams maybe they don't give us
two different products maybe just gives
us one right and this in this reaction
here we get this product e that would
just mean that the ease all that's left
over at the end of this reaction and the
mass of e will be equal to whatever mass
we started with it was 50 grams
initially then we'll have 50 grams here
same idea here if the massive a was 50
grams now of course doesn't have to be
50 grams right it could be any any
amount of mass but if this a decomposes
into F and G then that that means that
the mass is here will add up to be equal
to whatever we started with ok and these
are all general ideas now let's think
about a real life example this here is
the combustion of methane so the
combustion of methane and it is a
chemical reaction so we have methane
which is a CH 4 here this oxygen is a
combustion basically when we get carbon
dioxide and water and so I'm not gonna
go into all the details but let's just
say this let's say that let me just
propose a scenario let's say we had six
teen grams of methane and 64 grams of
oxygen react and then we ended up with
44 grams of carbon dioxide and 36 grams
of water does this obey the law of mass
conservation well I mentioned that it
was a chemical reaction so it has to
write 16 grams plus 64 grams that of
course equals 80 grams right and then 44
grams plus 36 grams also equals 80 grams
so these two values are equal right so
mass was conserved here so really what's
the idea here I keep you'll be saying it
over and over but it's the idea that the
mass of the reactants must equal the
mass of the products that's really what
this law says right sometimes it's
commonly stated as matter is conserved
or mass is conserved I've seen both
being said it's also commonly mentioned
as matter contorts commonly stated as
matter can be or semi cannot be created
or destroyed matter cannot be created or
destroyed it can only change form right
so we had in this first example up here
we had these 50 grams of matter in the
form of a and B and during the part of
the course the reaction at the end of
the reaction we have that same amount of
matter where I say mass right same on
mass just in different forms right in
the form of CND another question it's
important to ask is are there any
exceptions are there any exceptions the
idea of mass conservation and maybe
you've guessed the other the answer is
yes because I wrote the question down
and that would be a good guess the
answer is yes there there are except
there is an exception to the idea of
mass conservation and that's so that
we'll talk about later specifically with
nuclear reactions okay and so that does
not obey the law of mass conservation
we'll talk more on this more about this
later mass changes in these reaction
so that's pretty crazy but anyway I hope
that video itself was a quick intro to
this concept thank you for watching
don't forget to hit that video with a
like if you found it helpful or enjoyed
it and be sure to share with anyone else
for you thinking I find it helpful also
if you'd like to support the channel
follow move University on the different
social media links Twitter Facebook all
that stuff links in the description
below thanks and happy studying